cyber attacks against governments in
schools new IBM Z16 and IBM Linux 1 4
single frame and rack mount options and
the IBM Cloud for sap all on this
episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
we're going to start this episode with
some news out of the cyber security
world around cyber attacks on the public
sector
according to a recent report the number
of cyber attacks targeting government
agencies saw an increase of 95 percent
in 2022 compared to the same time frame
in 2021
these attacks predominantly targeted
government organizations in India the
United States Indonesia and China which
accounted for approximately 40 percent
of all incidents
now the covid-19 pandemic led to a rapid
digital migration in government
organizations including a significant
increase in remote systems access
of course this expands the attack
surface and allows malicious actors to
use cyber warfare as a means to Target
the public sector schools are being hit
too with almost 2 000 schools
potentially affected in 2022 compared to
around a thousand in the previous year
for the public sector tight budgets
often limit the ability to build an
adequate cyber defense so employee
training and education are more
important than ever hit the link below
to learn more about how to prepare your
team or organization
next up we're excited to introduce the
new single frame and rack mount
configurations of IBM Z16 and IBM Linux
1-4
the new offerings are built for the
modern data center to help optimize
flexibility and sustainability
particularly for small and medium-sized
businesses
the single frame and rack mount
configurations can even potentially help
reduce your carbon footprint for example
consolidating Linux workloads on IBM
Linux 1 Rockhopper 4. instead of running
them on comparable x86 servers with
similar conditions and location can
reduce energy consumption by 75 percent
in Space by 67 percent
the configurations can participate in
distributed hybrid Cloud environments
co-located with storage and compute and
you or a client's own racks to learn
more about these new offerings hit the
link below
finally I want to shine a spotlight on a
new report about IBM Cloud for sap many
sap customers are modernizing to Cloud
Erp to run their Finance supply chain
and HR operations so IBM commission
Forrester to determine the total
economic impact of moving sap Erp to
cloud and the results were stunning
Forester determined an Roi of 212
percent over three years for a present
value of 6.86 million dollars
this broke down to 2.6 million in
reduced operational risks from improved
availability 2.3 million in increased
operational efficiency 1.4 million in
reduced data center costs and 0.8
million in reduced compliance and
security risks
to learn more about the move to IBM
Cloud for sap and the benefits it brings
hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now